when I worried about privacy I worried
about peer to peer invasion of privacy
about the fact that anytime anything of
any note happens there are three arms
holding cell phones with cameras in the
more video recorders capturing the event
ready to go on the nightly news if
necessary and I think that does change a
lot our sense of what is going on in our
neighborhoods I mean right now we
basically smooth over everything we
don't hear about with an assumption that
it was an average day and now all of a
sudden anything not averaging the day
will be available for us to see and
indexed by location by time and probably
by actor and at that point i think our
whole perception of what's going on in
our towns or in other towns starts to
change I start to think of taking the
ingredients we already have and just
mixing them together so that on a base
of something like Flickr what you end up
with is an ability as you're standing at
a spot to say show me every picture
taken at this spot in the past ten years
that's been submitted to something like
Flickr if the spot happens to be a
reproductive health clinic or a flop
house or a church you can start to see
how there can be extra sensitivities to
that or you could just cross reference
and say show me every picture in which
this person appears through auto image
recognition even in just the background
so as I'm walking down the street
through something like Harvard Square or
Washington Square Park if I'm in the
background of anybody's video or camera
then I will be understood as having been
there at that time and i think that's
both powerful and interesting and also
an invasion of privacy of the sort that
making you worry about whether facebook
is you know telling people what product
you just bought somehow pales in
comparison
as we shift away from the personal
computer to more defined devices that
are themselves in touch with their
vendors at all times iPhones Kindles
nearly every mobile phone in fact these
devices are much more controllable not
just then by their vendors but by
anybody who regulates the vendors and
suddenly we could see as was attempted
by China in the green damn youth escort
project trying to see that every new pc
being sold in China would have filtering
software embedded in it that talks to
the mothership and can update itself on
what it will filter or even just what it
will do generally to have devices that
are already baked that way they don't to
be transformed that way by software but
out of the box that's how they behave I
think that is a wild card that could
change the initial observation that
everyday things are a little bit freer
and that's why I'd be keeping